dans les abysses est il mort on trouve
de tout à moscou il des braves des
cancers de bons restaurants services de
cloud contraste est donc tout le monde
d'avoir beaucoup watros c'est en août
que s'est passé je l'avais senti que
c'était possible de décrire la russie en
un seul mot moscou ce n'est pas la
russie on dit ici que c'est un état dans
l'état
une ville qui plus belle plus riche plus
moderne que partout ailleurs au pays on
y retrouve des jeunes qui ont grandi
avec plus de liberté que jamais et qui
chacun à leur manière aspirent à
transformer la russie piotr osipov à 26
ans jeune insouciant très doué en
communication il s'est lancé dans un
tout nouveau domaine en russie le
coaching d'affaires
il nous fait visiter ses locaux flambant
neufs
à peu près dans le mois n ce jour là ils
sont une vingtaine d'entrepreneurs qui
veulent aller plus loin plus vite
piotr les aide à se trouver une niche et
à développer des services pour la
nouvelle classe moyenne en chine ce
rachat et c'était difficile d'être en
affaires dans les années 90 parce que
c'était l'anarchie
maintenant il ya des lois et moins de
règlements de compte visa no09 la russie
a un avantage sur l'europe les états
unis et le japon maintenant on paie
moins d'impôts qu'en europe taxe
harmonisée venir
les priorités de tiko n'diaye coûts sont
ailleurs
il est journaliste il nous reçoit dans
un appartement imprégné d'histoire
il vient d'une famille de dissidents
soviétiques ses grands-parents des
écrivains ont même été emprisonné
aujourd'hui tikhon a le sentiment que
tout est bloqué après les 13 années au
pouvoir de vladimir poutine
il souhaite lui plus de démocratie et
plus de libertés c'est pas l'union
soviétique mais c'est une pays qui veut
être l'union soviétique
je ne suis pas d'accord avec ce régime
vous n'avez pas beaucoup de possibilités
de dans la politique dans la vie
culturelle dans tout parce que parce que
le pouvoir
les pouvoirs de contrôle sur surtout les
sphères après la réélection entachée de
fraudes du président russe tikhon
s'était joint aux grands rassemblements
pour affirmer l'existence d'une autre
russie un mouvement qui avait causé tout
un show ils ont décidé qu'ils qu'il faut
avoir pas juste l'argent il faut avoir
pas justin de confort il faut avoir
aussi le confort comme citoyen et je
pense qu à la frontière dont les jeunes
laissés à moscou si les droits de
l'homme à son sont et pourtant pour ou
ou où elle n'existe pas losing hervo
qian partagent les valeurs de tiqqun
c'est la chanteuse d'un des plus
célèbres groupes de rock alternatif
russie son groupe est aussi connue ici
que les pussy rails les artistes qui ont
repris le flambeau de la contestation du
régime dans quelques heures
elle chantera devant des milliers de
fans dans nos chansons on parle de tout
ce qui nous préoccupe ici la corruption
les injustices que vivent les personnes
âgées les handicapés et les chômeurs
cette conscience citoyenne est partagée
par beaucoup de russes des jeunes
urbains ou verts libéraux qui comme
elles veulent du changement
mais dans le climat actuel plus
répressifs plusieurs préfèrent sans
analyse selon un sondage
un jeune sur cinq quitterait la russie
pour étudier ou pour vivre mieux
gino coutinho je peux vous dire que mes
amis les plus intelligents les plus
progressistes partent vivre aux états
unis nord-ouest les autorités et s'est
dirigé un nouveau système de valeurs
pour rassembler le plus de gens possible
mais ça ne marche pas non pas on ne peut
pas imposer sa et ses valeurs ne sont
pas les vendre les vocaux petit nicolas
on allait beaucoup
puis autre osipov n'a pas le temps de
s'occuper politique
tous les jours il se lève alors il
s'entraîne avec certains de ses clients
cela fait partie de l'encadrement les
nouveaux entrepreneurs selon lui doivent
apprendre à mener une vie équilibrée une
forme d'éthique à ces nouvelles en
russie john thys amon et l'argent ne
fait pas le bonheur du yoga tout d'abord
il faut faire ce qu'on aime et les
affaires sont un outil qu'on utilise
pour aider les gens visiblement c'est
une philosophie qui attire les foules
je pense qu'ils achetaient du clip audio
des centaines de jeunes d'un peu partout
en russie se pressent pour pouvoir
assister aux ateliers 4 livre ses
conseils parle du succès tous ont
déboursé 30 mille dollars une somme
colossale ici pour une session de deux
mois avec son entreprise
la réussite pays formidable pour partir
en affaires avec lui j'ai augmenté mes
revenus
j'ai de nouveaux projets et je
m'implique dans des oeuvres de charité
un succès qui aurait bien aimé connaître
lusinchi elle aussi à participer aux
manifestations contre vladimir poutine
mais le régime s'est durci les opposants
ont fini par se décourager
le mouvement s'est essoufflé muhsin elle
va continuer de faire passer son message
dans ses chansons son espoir c'est que
les jeunes continuent de s'impliquer de
dénoncer
notre but ce n'est pas d'inciter les
gens à la révolution ou à la destruction
nous voulons réveiller les consciences
pour que les gens agissent être champion
quand je dis stores nixon après quoi
même espoir pour tiko comme ne s'imagine
pas vivre ailleurs qu'à moscou et il
vient d'obtenir un poste à la seule
chaîne de télévision indépendante encore
toléré en russie ce qu'il va continuer
de défendre les valeurs chères à ses
parents et à ses grands parents
quatre côtés je veux vivre dans le pays
avec faire avec des valeurs qui sont
absolument évident pour moi ce sont là
les valeurs de la vie
ce sont les valeurs de de liberté des
trois donc le détroit de l'ongle liberté
de l'expression
puis autre lui à d'autres idéaux il est
satisfait de pouvoir s'enrichir en
laissant à d'autres le soin de gérer le
pays
lui qui est parti de rien il ya à peine
trois ans roule aujourd'hui en
lamborghini il raffole de musique
français
il fréquente les plus beaux endroits de
moscou à redescendre j'ai gagné un
million de dollars moi et dans cette
ville dans cette russie moderne
d'aujourd'hui pour lui en tout cas tout
semble possible
l'idéal c'est d'avoir le ciel
britannique
une voiture italienne une amoureuse
française et de vivre en russie